one of the tests we had done yesterday
was the body pod which we had to sit
inside and it would measure different
things like our body fat
lean muscle lots of different things
that determine how healthy we are
and once we got out rick the dietitian
sat with us and showed us on the screen
what all the different figures were and
what they meant
for myself the body fat came out as 59
and just seeing it on the screen i was
just hoping it didn't mean what i
thought it did
that more than half my body is fat
and even saying it now it just
surprises me because i just didn't think
the figure was going to be as high as it
was
and
although you do need fat in your body
makes me see it as if i got rid of that
fat
i would be
half the size i currently am
and if that's not an incentive to lose
weight
and get healthy i don't know what is
we've all been given our diets now and
mine is the 5-2 diet now i've got the
diet
i'm looking forward to getting started
with it
and getting healthy